Speaker 1: This next segment is one of the
most embarrassing, humiliating segments I
have ever seen because it combines the pathetic
political perspective and cynicism of Fox
News with sending a reporter who has no business
speaking Spanish to the border to try to speak
Spanish.
Fox News has been playing up this narrative
that there's a crisis on the border that was
caused by Joe Biden.
It didn't exist up until January 20th and
that Joe Biden and Kamala Harris are ignoring
it because they refuse to go to the border.
This is the story that they have been telling.
So Fox News sends a reporter to the border
to talk to people and they decided to send
Griff Jenkins and Griff Jenkins.
Listen, this is a guy who's been embarrassing
himself on Fox News for a decade, but he goes
and talks to a random guy who's just in the
river and he's believed to be in.
Later, we find out that he is someone who
helps get people to the U.S. Mexico border
who are looking to cross into the United States.
It's just a random guy sitting in the water
and up walks Fox News reporter Griff Jenkins
and tries to speak Spanish.
And this you just have to see.
Let's look at the first clip.
Check it out.
Speaker 2: Smuggler is coming over towards
us.
I'm just going to take a moment and ask him
a few questions.
Come us.
More, more or less, we the under.
See, now, I don't
Speaker 1: even know what he said there.
Remember, I'm a native Spanish speaker, what
I think I heard is more Losman us rather than
last menos more plus minus the Ambre, which
translates painfully literally as more the
arms of hunger.
And again, I'm like doing the best I can to
make sense of the syntax here.
So then the guy has no idea what's going on
and is just sort of waving.
And Overstock's Griff Jenkins and this continues.
Speaker 2: Publishing lies no contest.
Pugin, Chrissa.
Let's not make out this.
Speaker 1: Now, so there Jenkins is asking
in a very strangely phrased way, how much
are you getting paid for helping immigrants
cross the border?
The guy says nothing.
I think that, unfortunately, as embarrassing
as this is, the average Fox News viewer sees
this and thinks, wow, this is like really
good investigative journalism.
This is great stuff.
And that's a media literacy problem as much
as this is a really harebrained idea by FOX.
My guess is a lot of their core viewers love
this.
Let's continue.
And this is my favorite part.
Speaker 2: Can I say a la president that bottom.
OK, well, Neil, he's not saying anything about
how much he's getting paid or if he has a
message for President Biden, but he does say
that more people are coming.
Not entirely sure why the smuggler is sitting
in the middle of the river here.
We're going to continue to monitor it and
bring it to you as we get it.
Neil.
Speaker 1: Incredible.
I just love that because, first of all, why
would this guy have a message for Joe Biden?
But I love that he says LA President Biden,
which is the feminine form of the question,
implying Biden is a woman, that we have a
female president.
It's not on purpose.
It's not like this guy's trying to emasculate
Biden.
He just has no idea how to speak Spanish.
And this was a bad idea from the get go.
So then apparently producers just love this
so much.
They the producers were thrilled.
So they they got more of this footage of Fox
News asking a guy sitting in a river for his
opinion on American immigration policy.
And Joe Biden
Speaker 2: Norinco by attacking a lie that
Kubica, you're not coming for, you know, Bianna.
Speaker 1: So here the guy seems to be saying,
I only come to this point.
I don't go any further because that's beyond
the border.
That would be illegal.
I'm not doing that.
And this guy is scared and I would be, too.
And then Jenkins' again starts up with the
Biden questions,
Speaker 2: c, e, l, President Biden.
Abla Frontera is Cerrado.
Speaker 1: So what Jenkins is trying to say
there in some of just the worst Spanish that
I've ever heard is that Joe Biden says the
border is closed and this guy responds, but
no one's understanding each other.
And it's a complete and total mess
Speaker 2: because it isn't getting us out
of the game regardless.
I mean, I know we're getting guns out of see
is is from there, although I have to get louder
and louder.
Oh, I hope he's had that problem.
But I thought, you know, you buy a ticket
on my.
Attacking the Iran killer is a message for
President Obama to undo while his death, but
there's a bottom here.
Speaker 1: So the guy says, well, build the
bridge, then people are tired and the reporter
says again, but it's closed.
The border is closed.
And the guy says, we'll open it.
But it's not legal to go beyond the river.
So that's why I stopped here when I'm helping
people.
But the best part of this is the guy says
when asked for his message to Joe Biden, he
says, oh, no, I have no problem.
But, you know, do do what you're doing.
You guys are good.
Not exactly the ominous threatening message
from coyotes that Fox News wants us to believe.
And it continues getting more and more interesting
Speaker 2: in Mexican all American policy
on Mexico.
No, no, no, no, sir.
Not Native American policy.
I don't hear of a new wife, man.
Speaker 1: That is just the best.
The guy says, you know, in Mexico, the police
are no good.
You guys are good.
I respect you.
I don't even think Jenkins has any idea the
conversation that he's having with this guy.
Let's watch a little bit more.
Speaker 2: And Bearpark for one PRK cruiser
cruiser this.
But I at as I know America, I know Bearcat
guillotining.
I can see as Trayvon, though.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So so then Jenkins asks, why are you helping
people cross?
And the guy says to help people that are struggling
for the American dream, he literally says
for the American dream, because here in Mexico
they're screwing people.
So a few thoughts on this.
First of all, this guy is incredibly sympathetic,
if you can understand him, which, you know,
you really can't unless you speak Spanish,
because what's going it?
There's no translator.
It's just a pathetic mess.
If the idea is to frame what's happening as
really bad people helping really bad people
cross, it fails.
If you can understand what's being said, this
guy is super sympathetic to me.
But more importantly, no one really knows
because there's no translation.
This guy speaks no English.
Griff Jenkins speaks essentially no Spanish.
If you want to do this seriously, you could
do it seriously.
This is a side show.
They turn this into a freak show.
Jenkins doesn't even speak Spanish.
You don't know what the guy is saying.
And you really can't actually do justice to
a segment that could be quite interesting.
If you want to do this, you bring in a translator
and you might actually have a serious segment
here.
Griff Jenkins should be ashamed of himself.
So should Fox News.
Let me know what you think.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that The David Pakman Show does depend
on the support of people like you who get
a membership at Join Pakman Dotcom, we produce
an extra show every day, really
every weekday, OK, we take weekends off for
our paid members and you can get instant access
to that bonus show by signing up at Join Pakman
Dotcom